unbelievably poor graphics dire gameplay
shocking acting and absolutely no PO to
go back again after the Power has been
switched up makes the sniper to the
worst game I have ever played
unbelievably poor shocking and dying one
out of ten was that necessary
oh my god wow wow they look so good look
right now right now is nothing to do
with this right now is nothing to do
you're right CA I have had my revenge I
don't have to live like that anymore to
be on edge all the time
[Laughter]
Oh Oh snake the mafiosi
[Music]
what is even holding is he supposed to
hold a gun oh that was takes one crate
right look kid I'll do a save here just
in case just to make sure that I don't
lose my all that progress
over hitting one button oh there's
turtle eyes too now oh no coming this
way I see them yeah is that fun at the
end of them see a hairy no hey it's that
guy again what
[Music]
what No
no now
yeah that was ten minutes
no they're trolling there's no way oh
thank god I was like what that's fun
Oh son now the next movie starts the
sniper to a man looking for trouble okay
alright okay yeah the target is the arms
dealer Hey look at those graphics
oh [ __ ] god dammit [ __ ] this is really
hard it's like actual bullet drop in
this game oh there's a crosswalk there's
a crosswalk coming up no no no no no
oh god I'm running out of time I'm right
shoot he's running No
[Music]
shoot the case in the instant it changes
hands we got to find the Tacoma is that
the Tekamah king failure is not
acceptable
listen I'm trying I'm trying my best
here okay I'm trying to get the tech but
there's a chuckle McKenna I found it I
spotted the tuckle my cane alright we
gotta shoot the briefcase at the time of
the tech oh god damn he's fast he's so
fast alright make the exchange makes a
are they making the exchange they're
making the exchange power real soldier
fights you will forget everything
Hollywood taught not today son not today
no second my pattern for you son that's
right oh he pissed himself he peed
himself incredible
[Music]
there's not time to say anything more
but I'm fine okay don't worry about me
CA hey it's a horse
Oh the lingering lies between people the
subtle probing of other's thoughts
dishonesty everywhere they didn't even
bother animating this hey hey how ok
which one is it
that's the guy right no there's the guy
where you going son
oh no you don't know best game best game
I have ever played after breathing that
tackle McCann gasps we had to take part
in the operation like it or not the
operation was to retrieve the tackle
McCann antidote along with all the data
pertaining to it ca was taken by the
former CI age Gabriel Silva beyond
stratified let me to work Anna laughs
Archipelago tactic Stanley you get to
tackle McCann are we getting the tackle
he has to tackle my can you find
anything else attack on Mackay no
antidote just general data for its
production and this we don't have long
let's get started
tackle McCain I need the antidote yes
yeah oh oh I get it
I got a move I got a run run run Maine
run oh my god this is so exciting it's
no time
I know that it's no time damn it
God the last one and I got one more
bullet you will learn how a real soldier
fight ten seconds to get this far what
are you doing here oh my god I've had a
change of heart
no quick give us an adult
give us a taco McCain well tell us where
you hidden it see so that's the one she
fed you I don't have it
oh my god the pause the senator that
you're searching for it never existed in
the first place why you have to be
infected as well
Oh what's he gonna do he was Saphira
[Music]
see a let's move okay what is happening
No Oh No now Stanley
nuts and Lake Dam where's the shooter
get you you son of rich now and green RC
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know Larry wait for this moment I am a
sniper
Larry anything is my job I'm going to
the underground base we're out of time I
know you'll have to protect yourself now
don't trust anyone
yeah ready
go
whoa oh is that him that's it oh he's
strafing good shot where's this pub gee
you can't just straight Hey got him this
instant kill no matter where you hit him
did you get him
no he's sleeping yes okay
[Music]
and that was the end that was the actual
end good good good good good
good very good
you can finish it in less than an hour
or oh my god